En grandissant dans le Missouri,
ils nous menaient dans la forêt
et ils nous donnaient une carte et une boussole
et nous devions rentrer chez nous.
Sans la boussole,
on ne peut même pas lire la carte.
Voilà ce dont je viens vous parler.
La boussole est la clé.
[Petite chose.]
[Grande idée.]
Une boussole est tout simplement une pièce de métal magnétisée
de façon à ce qu'elle pointe vers le pôle magnétique de la Terre.
Celle à laquelle nous pensons tous est la boussole de poche.
Elle a l'air d'une montre, non ?
Vous pouvez la tenir dans votre main et observer l'aiguille tournoyer
jusqu'à trouver le nord.
Le magnétisme est encore une force mystérieuse pour les physiciens
mais ce dont nous sommes certains,
c'est que la boussole fonctionne parce que la Terre est un aimant géant.
Et quand vous utilisez une boussole,
vous êtes en contact avec le centre-même de notre planète,
où cette sorte de boule turbulente de fer en fusion
tourne sur elle-même et crée un champ magnétique.
Comme un aimant avec lequel vous pouvez jouer sur votre table,
elle possède un pôle nord et un pôle sud.
Nous utilisons des boussoles pour indiquer le nord pour cette raison.
La plus vieille boussole connue date de 200 Av. JC et vient de Chine.
Ils ont compris que certains métaux qui proviennent du sol
sont naturellement magnétiques.
Ils ont donc transformé ces métaux magnétiques en une espèce de louche,
l'ont déposée sur une plaque cuivrée et elle pointait le nord.
Cela aurait été principalement utilisé pour améliorer le feng shui,
afin de déterminer la manière optimale de faire circuler l'énergie
à travers leurs espaces de vie.
Les marins furent probablement parmi les premiers adeptes
de la version plus portative
car où que soit le soleil,
quelles que soient les conditions des étoiles,
ils pouvaient toujours trouver le nord.
Beaucoup plus tard, les Européens ont innové
et ont imaginé la rose des vents.
Elle donnait la disposition du nord, du sud, de l'est et de l'ouest,
et elle permettait aussi de créer de nouvelles directions
telles que le nord-ouest, le sud-est, etc.
Et pour la première fois, ils savaient où ils allaient.
C'était formidable, mais je crois que cela faisait partie
de la re-dynamisation générale de la science en Europe,
connue sous le nom de Renaissance.
Beaucoup de nouveaux outils furent inventés,
du téléscope au microscope.
Les cartes se sont améliorées grâce à la boussole, non ?
Parce qu'avec, on commence à comprendre où sont les directions,
vous obtenez beaucoup plus de détails,
et cela change la relation que l'humain a avec le monde.
La boussole avec une carte est comme un super-pouvoir.
Tout ce que nous considérons comme l'histoire du monde
n'aurait pas eu lieu sans la boussole.
Les grandes découvertes, le tour du globe de Magellan,
et même le fait de savoir que c'est un globe.
La boussole finit par être intégrée dans tous ces autres outils,
parce que cela fonctionne si bien.
Vous pouvez en avoir une dans votre outil multi-usages
ou une incrustée dans votre téléphone.
La boussole est partout,
parce qu'elle permet littéralement de se repérer sur la surface de la Terre.
Vous pouvez donc partir, explorer
et découvrir ce qu'il y a au-delà de cette colline ou de l'horizon,
mais vous êtes aussi assuré de trouver votre chemin du retour.